es gibt wieder mal ein neues foto von
angela merkel beim shoppen in berlins
luxuskaufhaus kadewe seit anfang
dezember ist ja nun keine kanzlerin mehr
fast auf den tag genau fünf monate und
so langsam fragt man sich was macht sie
eigentlich die ganze zeit und was hat
sie in zukunft vor eine frau die 16
jahre lang quasi nonstop im dienst war
kann schotten ja nicht reichen oder
ganz aktuelle bilder der ehemaligen
kanzlerin angela merkel bild
leser-reporter fotografieren wie sie mit
voll gepackten tüten durchs berliner
kadewe läuft was drin ist wissen wir
nicht vor wenigen wochen reist sie mit
freunden durch italien so sieht er aus
der uhr stand der alt kanzlerin
vor knapp fünf monaten verabschiedet sie
sich aus dem amt jetzt können wir mit
erleben die sich merkel einrichtet im
ruhestand lange hatte sie selbst keine
idee von der zeit nach dem
[Musik]
wird dann schon mit der zeit was
anfangen könnten
der kanzlerinnen blazer bleibt
jedenfalls immer noch nicht im schrank
entdeckt
dafür trägt sie bequeme schuhe auf der
shopping tour durchs berliner
luxuskaufhaus und mit dabei zwei
sicherheitsleute die sind auch auf der
reise durch italien dabei und gehören
zum renten paket einer kanzlerin neben
15.000 euro monatlich einem büro mit
fünf mitarbeitern und zwei fahrern und
was macht eine art kanzlerin
es strömt vorher denke die geht
spazieren und das sollte auch putin in
seinem alter tun und ein bisschen
schachspielen und die relaxt genau was
ich mache nicht glücklich leben
nachdenken
das denkt sich merkel wohl auch sie
taucht nur selten in der öffentlichkeit
auf für schauspieler ulrich matthes
macht sie eine ausnahme als er das
bundesverdienstkreuz vom
bundespräsidenten verliehen bekommt
vermissen die deutschen ihre mutti
sollte sie sich wieder mehr einmischen
genug zu tun gäbe es in diesen zeiten
gemacht von daher
also dass ich vielleicht
europa stärkt ich habe so das gefühl
dass herr scholz ein bisschen abdriftet
oder vielleicht zu leise ist
nach templin fahren und war auf ihrem
grundstück
langweilig ist ihr sicher nicht aber
warum trägt sie immer noch den
kanzlerinnen blazer sehen sie sich
vielleicht doch heimlich nach ihrem
alten job sogar auf der shopping tour
durchs kadewe